c'est daniel qui chantait sans astérix
avanies très bien merci oui je suis
prête à couper les cheveux dit non tout
regarder vraiment les cheveux
complètement a enfin il y en a à peine 2
cm là on prend vraiment pour une fille
parce que tous les garçons les cheveux
longs ah bon c'est pour ça que les
données oui parce que tu portes aussi
tout le temps des pantalons j'ai
remarqué non pas tout le temps quand
même c'est quand même une de tes
vêtements favori tu lis et avec sa wii
un coup c'est pas terrible c'est * oui
je sais quelle différence y at-il entre
* et astérix aucune pas manquer aucune
je crois pas ce que ça veut rien dire
quoi par du tout à ce terrible c'est la
déformation gauloise et ô combien de *
les et périls ah oui c'est vrai nom un
astérisque annoncé ce temps alex terry
ce que c'est un petit signe qu'on
l'historique regarde surtout en papier
ses marques entre les rixes le gaulois
et ben tu sais aussi bien que moi ce que
c'est bon bah tiens bon tu as fait
d'autres chansons d'imaginer sursaut dit
oui et elle a une autre qui s'appelle le
chpo et ça veut dire quoi exactement
d autres types ce promeneur et
maintenant il y en a une qui s'appelle
la fia la moto lyautey s'appelle la
coupe est pleine a bat la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase
mais non ce prix
[Musique]